welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast
today's episode is a special one because
we're focusing entirely on q and a's so
we've gathered up a bunch of questions
from listeners
and today we answer them in this episode
we talk about things like the relative
impact of
lifting and protein intake on muscle
protein synthesis
strategies for dealing with sub-optimal
sleep patterns
how to handle anti-lifting advice from
your doctor
nutritional strategies that may or may
not reduce muscle loss during
detraining how hard you should train
studies that we would like to see
completed in the future
topics where our opinion is firmly
against the common wisdom
and much more as always thank you for
listening and we hope you enjoy the show
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only
permanent host eric trexler today i am
joined by a special temporary guest
co-host
his name is greg knuckles greg how are
you doing today
i am doing well how are you i am doing
well actually that's a [ __ ] lie
i'm not doing well yeah i i broke my arm
two days ago and uh
[ __ ] sucks man would not recommend but
uh
i mean in a in a cosmic sense i'm doing
well i guess
uh in the grand scheme of things broken
arm
annoying small setback shouldn't dwell
on it
so yeah overall i'm doing well i'm going
back to my original
answer yeah and i i can confirm for all
the skeptics out there
there is significant bruising uh clearly
a break has occurred
uh very unfortunate to see but uh
hopefully you'll be
on the mend and back to 100 very soon
hope so all right so uh a little note to
listeners this is going to be
a special q a episode uh
normally with the show we've got a bunch
of different segments
that is the formula that brought us
right to the top of the podcasting
industry
we are abandoning that for today's
episode only
because we get a lot of questions that
get submitted and it's impossible to
stay on top of all of them but
you know every now and then we like to
dig into the vault and uh
and give you the answers that you uh so
desperately crave
as listeners so a bunch of different q
and a's here
and i'm going to kick things off with a
question from angus
and for my questions greg you got a
bunch of new ones
from the stronger by science community
group
and it if you're not a member of that
facebook group
the link for that facebook group is in
the uh description
of today's episode but i went back all
the way to like
day one uh so the questions that i'm
drawing from were submitted in like 2019
the people who ask them probably don't
even listen anymore i mean statistically
speaking
they probably don't even lift anymore
probably not
yeah but uh anyway if if these people
are out there
uh thanks for being with us from
literally day one
so i got a question from angus here and
the question is
how does muscle protein synthesis caused
by protein consumption
compared to the magnitude of muscle
protein synthesis
caused by resistance training um
lifting is a huge huge driver of muscle
protein synthesis
and uh you know a lot of times we'll
look at these studies
and we'll kind of quibble over the
details of
this protein source versus that protein
source
in the first few hours after ingestion
how large of a response in muscle
protein synthesis do they induce
and indeed when we look with that
particular approach
to the question there are some
differences between protein sources it
can be
really it can be really tempting to get
really caught up in those small
differences between specific protein
sources
it can be really tempting to get caught
up in
trying to optimize very nuanced
protein timing strategies based on that
research but
sometimes we forget uh
the magnitude of of how much basically
how that
those magnitudes scale when we look at
the effect of acute proteins
consumption versus the the impact of
resistance training or lifting
lifting is an enormous driver a very
very
potent driver of muscle protein
synthesis
and there are some cool instances where
we can really see
how big of an impact resistance training
has so
one study that comes to mind is the
androgen deprivation study by hanson and
colleagues
from a few years ago but but they looked
at the muscle protein response
muscle protein synthesis response to to
protein feeding
in people who are undergoing androgen
deprivation therapy
as part of their cancer treatment i
believe and then
a group of control participants
and the the differences in kind of
baseline muscle protein synthesis
uh were quite notable but resistance
training itself
went a very long way in terms of closing
that gap
in that kind of resting muscle protein
synthesis
and it's pretty remarkable to think of
how big of an
impact it would have to have to overcome
that gap
induced by androgen deprivation we also
see glimpses of this when we look at the
immobilization literature so
there are a number of different studies
that uh investigate this question or
this problem
and it's a big problem immobilization
happens a lot um
you know let's say for instance you
broke a limb
uh you might be casted for a while and
so you'll be
that limb will be immobilized and people
are always wondering
during immobilization whether it's due
to inactivity
uh or or uh casting or bracing or some
other reason
are there nutritional strategies that
can attenuate
the loss of strength or the loss of lean
mass and the nutritional strategies have
pretty low efficacy
honestly they're pretty underwhelming
sometimes you'll see studies that try to
just
bump up dietary protein a little bit uh
they don't tend to have a really big
impact
on the degree of muscle wasting there
are some studies that i will talk about
a little
later that look at higher dose
supplementation with either essential
amino acids or leucine specifically
mixed findings some of them have a small
benefit but
by far the most important thing you can
do
during a layoff or during immobilization
is if it's possible
do some degree of muscular loading some
degree
of resistance training if possible in
many cases that's not going to be doable
most of the time that limb is
immobilized for a reason and you're not
going to be able to do any significant
loading but
uh the the impact of resistance training
is very substantial and of a much larger
magnitude than some of the little
dietary differences
with regards to protein intake that we
tend to obsess over
um it's even it's interesting when you
look at the research on layoffs from
training
uh you know there's research showing
even if you cut your volume by like 85
90
just doing some of that training volume
can
can go a really long way in preserving
strength and muscle gains
during a layoff uh so yeah resistance
training is
really driving the stimulus but of
course these things go hand in hand
right so
if you are for whatever reason
certainly not a recommendation if you're
doing resistance training but
really intentionally restricting your
protein intake you're not going to
maximize your gains
that's not a good strategy there is a
bit of an additive effect when we have
a really good strategy in terms of
protein sources and protein timing
and the amount of protein when we
combine that with an efficacious
resistance training program
that's a good thing the two work
together uh
and having both of those strategies in
unison is better than having one or the
other
same thing you could have a really great
muscle building diet
and you've got your protein amount
sorted out
you've got a good distribution of
protein throughout the day decent timing
of those servings
you could have all the nutritional
components right but if you don't have a
stimulus for growth
if you don't have the resistance
training it's not going to do that
much in terms of supporting gains in
muscle mass or gains and lean
in lean tissue so there is kind of a
combination effect
where you want to make sure that you
have a robust training stimulus
to induce or to really drive hypertrophy
but you also want to have the correct
nutritional support to maximize that
response so
resistance training drives the stimulus
i would say that
dietary strategies related to protein
have more of a permissive role in terms
of maximizing the adaptation to it
and that is my answer so you've got one
now
from hyoto hayato
i'd assume it's hayato hayato yeah uh
yeah from hayato nishiyama he asks uh
why don't researchers start tracking
sleep and include it in their analysis
uh this is a very easy or this is very
easy using a sleep tracker app
it may not be the most accurate thing
but i feel like it's better or more
accurate
than self-reported nutritional intake
sometimes researchers don't even include
those self-reports into their analysis
so i don't see the point uh i assume the
implication there is i don't see the
point in
not also tracking sleep uh so yeah
why don't uh exercise science
researchers
track and report subjects sleep habits
uh and i think that there are a couple
reasons for that i think first and
foremost
um it's
the the most basic reason i think uh
is simply that there's not yet any
research
that i'm aware of at least showing that
not sleeping enough impacts your gains
um and i very much think that it
does but i don't think that's
yet been empirically demonstrated so
you know there have been some some
short-term studies and there have
certainly been some acute studies
showing that if uh you know
if you extend the amount you're sleeping
for
a couple weeks performance increases a
bit
or if you restrict sleep
severely for one night or
a couple of nights or if you just
completely go without sleep for one
night
maybe there will be some performance
decrements but i'm not aware of any
especially resistance training studies
where you know they put
two people or they put two they put
people in two different groups
uh one group sleeps you know a normal
amount
uh seven to nine hours per night another
group sleeps
i don't know five six hours per night
for eight weeks and then see what
strength gains and hypertrophy look like
i very much think that sleeping a
sufficient amount is beneficial but
it's you know you only have
finite research resources
uh and you know you can collect as many
variables
or as many outcome measures as you could
want to
you know try to find little things that
are associated with with x y and z
uh but generally if you're if you're
playing things by the book
you primarily want to focus on things
that have been shown
to be associated with whatever outcome
variable you're
interested in so one of the reasons that
scientists
do frequently look at self-reported
nutrition intake
even if as you acknowledged
self-reported nutrition intake
isn't necessarily the best and most
accurate measure
we do know that total caloric intake
whether someone's in a deficit or a
surplus
will probably impact their ability to
gain strength and muscle
and certainly if they're eating adequate
levels of protein or not so
nutritional variables have been shown to
uh modify the responses we're interested
in usually
muscle growth and strength gains and
even though
it would be very intuitive to assume
that sleep does as well
that that quantitative evidence
just doesn't exist yet so the the first
step would just be to
um find some very understanding
participants half of whom
might be willing to only sleep five or
six hours per night for
eight to twelve weeks uh and the other
half
sleeping a normal amount and see you
know does not sleeping enough
impact your gains you'd also need to
find a very understanding irb to approve
that because
it's generally understood not sleeping
enough not a particularly great thing
and the people who are tasked with
keeping human
research subjects safe may not be too
enthused with that idea so anyway
uh there are certainly some hurdles
there but yeah one of the reasons that
people don't collect that data
is just because you you'd have a hard
time
justifying the collection of that data
and reporting it in the study just
because
uh it hasn't been shown yet to affect
the outcome measures people are
interested in
um and i think the other
i mean i i think the other major reason
uh is just that
it's another variable that would
probably be
of relatively low quality because
you know you could go about it a couple
different ways
you could just ask for self-reported
sleep data so
you know how much did you sleep last
night and on a scale from 1 to 10
how high of quality do you feel that
sleep was
i actually did that for my thesis
research project
um looking at whether
either quantity or perceived quality of
sleep
was associated with recovery rates from
a standardized fatigue protocol uh
and i found that it was not um
if memory serves actually soreness at 24
hours post training
was actually positively associated with
sleep duration
the previous night which if you took
that at face value you would say like oh
sleeping a lot makes you more sore
and recover more poorly but i mean i i
think that was probably just a spurious
correlation
but yeah i mean you can collect that
data but
it's probably not going to be the
highest quality if it's self-reported
and the the question asks or
specifically brings up sleep tracker
apps i don't know that those have been
validated against gold standard measures
of
sleep either so you know i
ideally there's like little little
helmet things people put on that have
electrodes on them that can
actually measure brain waves and so
uh like sleep researchers can actually
see like hey
when are when are these brain waves
shifting so we know the person has
actually fallen asleep
we know how much time they spend in rem
sleep stage four sleep etc
i don't i don't know that any of the
sleep tracker apps
on the market have been validated
against gold standard measures like that
so
if they haven't i mean whether you're
using an app or just using self report
it's it's going to be more low quality
data
and i mean unless you're an
exceptionally well-funded lab
um you're not going to be able to use
gold standard sleep measures
on all of your subjects uh especially if
they're not
you know like inpatient like if you're
not working out of a metabolic ward
which i mean
you won't be so yeah i mean
ultimately it would probably be a low
quality measure
and uh until
sleep duration or quality is actually
empirically
shown to be uh predictive of or
associated with hypertrophy and strength
gains which again
i'm not expressing skepticism towards
that concept i very much think it is
but but that needs to be empirically
validated before
you'd have a strong justification to add
another
relatively low quality measure to the
data that you're reporting
yeah i think that's a great point and
you know one of the issues like you said
is it's not a
super robust high quality piece of
information
to put into the model you could end up
with some spurious outcomes that are
unanticipated and
might you know it might be tempting to
over interpret them and follow some
lines of thinking that maybe aren't
really solid
another thing is a lot of times we're
talking about pretty small sample
research and
there's just simply a limit to how many
variables you can try to jam into
a single model when you've got very few
participants
and that's kind of a logistical
constraint it's it's very bad
practice to have you know eight in each
group and say oh yeah we're going to
control for 13 dietary variables and
look at the effect of the intervention
uh it's it's logistically not something
that can really be done
and so yeah when we're talking about
small sample research i think
some people get into this field as a
student and they're like oh i'm going to
become a statistical mastermind
and learn all the really nuanced fancy
stuff
and then they kind of are in you know
they're a grad student for a couple
years and they're like wait a minute
we can't use any of this stuff can we
and it's like yeah not really
uh you know all the really cool fancy
stuff usually require sample sizes that
we're just never going to have
unless you're doing some observational
stuff
with uh survey data or something like
that so
yeah there's just logistical constraints
yeah i mean for the most part we can
have
one or maybe two covariates with the
sample sizes we're dealing with and you
know more often than not
uh the covariate is just going to be
like if you run an ancova
just baseline measures of whatever
measure you're taking so
you know uh changes in fastest lateralis
thickness
covariance for baseline vastus lateralis
thickness i mean that that's probably
the most intuitive covariate and then uh
maybe you could justify sneaking one
more and like
total protein intake or something like
that but yeah uh
that that is a good point even if you
have the sleep data
statistically you wouldn't really be
able to justify
including it most of the time it would
just be an additional
number reported in a table that you
weren't actually using in your main
analyses so yeah
it that makes it even harder to justify
including yeah uh and
before we leave the topic that's why you
see a lot of researchers who just
collect the nutrition stuff they take a
look at it and they don't factor it into
the
the analysis is they basically just want
to see you know hey did my supplement
group have twice the protein of my
control group for no reason
if so i've got a problem it doesn't you
know doesn't always make its way into
the analysis though
um okay so i've got a couple questions
here that are kind of related so i'm
going to answer both of them at once
uh josh vl asked
how would you personally respond to a
medical professional that tells you to
stop squatting because it's bad for
for your knees um so i'm going to start
with that one
both of them are kind of injury related
um
so first of all you know a medical
professional tells you
to modify your training for
health related reasons or injury related
reasons
whenever i get that feedback
from somebody they reach out send me a
message say their doctor said this their
doctor said that
my first reaction is to cut the medical
professional a little bit of slack
not to be too harsh or too critical of
them because it's really important that
we remember what their job
is as a kind of general practitioner
medical professional uh you know the
advice you get from a sports medicine
doctor
who specializes working with high level
athletes
is probably going to be pretty different
than the advice you get from a general
general practitioner a lot of times the
the
medical professionals that we're seeing
uh as members of the general population
are not specialized in
elite performance or you know
professional athletics or anything like
that
their job is you know someone comes with
an issue
with symptoms with some activity that
might
contribute to symptoms or cause symptoms
their job is to make sure that those
symptoms aren't around
and aren't uh you know mod
you know having a big impact on
day-to-day life and altering quality of
life
so you know if you go to a doctor and
say yeah every time i bench press my
shoulder hurts
they're just gonna say hey maybe lay off
the bench press
that is their job for the most part like
on a very simple level
uh you could argue about you know maybe
that shouldn't be but i think a lot of
medical
practitioners are looking for the most
parsimonious way
to solve your problem and if your
problem is you're doing a non-essential
activity that causes a symptom
they're going to tell you to cease the
non-essential activity yeah
their priority is making sure you can
perform activities of daily living or
you know basic job functions with uh
minimal discomfort and maximal efficacy
and they'll
prescribe a pretty uh pretty
conservative treatment plan to do that
they're they're interested in can you go
about day-to-day life
and work pain-free not how much do you
squat
yeah and before we get the the comments
i'm sure that there are a lot of people
in the medical field on some other
podcast who are probably debating
whether or not that's how
the healthcare field should operate you
know there's probably
i have to assume a contingent of
practitioners who say hey we need to
start treating the person in a more
comprehensive way and considering their
their hobbies their interests their
their lifestyle
so i don't i don't qualify to have an
opinion on that i'm just telling you
what what the typical general
practitioners
kind of operating with or their kind of
viewpoint that i think
in many cases is defensible based on you
know their training and their focus area
uh it's kind of unfair to walk in to
your general practitioner's office and
like a
family medicine setting and say like
okay so treat me as if i'm an olympian
and they're like yeah i don't
i don't do that um but anyway yeah so i
try to cut them some slack i try to
contextualize that advice but
you know i think it can be really
helpful rather than just
kind of being upset with your mec with
your medical professional
i do think we live in a really
interesting time where you can access
people who do have medical credentials
uh pretty easily uh you know you can do
a consultation with somebody
uh virtually who really does specialize
working with lifters working with
athletes
and so yeah you might set up a call with
somebody who
is a doctor or a physical therapist or
or something like that who
gets it and who's like okay we can work
with this
uh let's contextualize this let's
consider your lifestyle consider your
passions and hobbies
and we can put together an alternative
plan that isn't so conservative
i remember back when i was uh you know a
high school athlete
the coaches would always say for the
love of god don't go to your doctor
like just and they met i mean they were
good they were good folks
but like you've probably heard that
advice too right yeah yeah like your
high school coach is like just go to the
athletic trainer
they'll let you know if you need to get
like real medical intervention because
we
we'd have all these kids who go to the
doctor because their ankle hurts and
their doctor's like yeah you have some
non-specific ankle tweak and therefore
uh don't do anything for like 12 weeks
and it's like
that's for our purposes pretty
unnecessary
right so uh yeah i would say don't don't
beat up on your medical professional but
do
seek out a second opinion from someone
who who can
really understand where you're coming
from and understand your perspective
and you know the next thing to keep in
mind is you know like i said that the
medical professionals likely trying to
give you advice to like you said greg
just get you through activities of daily
living and occupational tasks
but when it comes to our hobbies
especially if they're a little bit more
extreme you know
if you really i mean it's not like we're
like you know
doing uh stuntman work or anything like
that but
you know there's some there's some risk
involved with really heavy lifting you
know i like to go
skiing people break limbs tear acls
and have more serious injuries doing
that stuff you know you can't
live your life based on you know an
actuary table
and saying okay what's going to maximize
my
probability of living to the age of what
like 78 or whatever
uh so you know with life we have a
cost-benefit analysis
and your medical professional might have
a
different waiting system for costs and
benefits so
you might just have to have a
conversation with them explain
how you weigh those costs and benefits
and see if they can kind of work with
you and give you some
updated information that's actually
useful to you but
um yeah and sometimes you're going to
get medical professionals who just
aren't really
up to date with training information
nutrition information i'm sure there are
a lot of medical professionals who say
some
really outdated stuff about the topics
that we obsess over
but it's just not their focal point it's
it's not their area where they spend
most of their time
so you have to understand that and seek
out people who can really level with you
and understand your concerns yeah and
just to build on that
uh i very much endorse not living your
life
based on actuarial tables uh the
stronger my science podcast supports
living your life a quarter mile at a
time
fast and furious nine proud sponsors of
the stronger by science podcast
uh fast nine comes out i believe
tomorrow
uh in american theaters and i assume
around the world either
then or soon thereafter uh go see it
it's gonna be about family it's gonna be
about john cena
uh all good things i'm surprised they
went with that title instead of
nine fast nine curious
i think that would have been would have
been great uh okay
the second question that i had here is
also dude i'm so stoked i [ __ ] love
fast and furious
i don't know why i i saw the one and i
just thought it was ridiculous
so i i have uh i have
a very specific taste in movies i see in
theaters
and that is the bigger and dumber an
action flick is
the better it is to watch in the
theaters and uh
in terms of just like a big fun dumb
summer popcorn movie franchise you
really can't do better than fast and
furious
they're all so stupid
uh but so much fun to watch in a theater
yeah i just i i absolutely love them i
jumped into the series on i think number
four
or five uh as you know i like to wait
till a series really gets going
and then jump in without context uh only
when someone makes me
so i went to the fifth one with somebody
who really liked
the first four i think and uh a
character
comes on the screen and she just kind of
like
nudges me with her elbow and goes oh by
the way she doesn't remember
most things but sometimes she does and i
was like you know what
if i was writing a movie that would be a
very convenient
device to use in my plot yeah when you
want her to have a
very persistent memory issue she does
but sometimes she doesn't
and that's good um anyway moving on i've
got a question
from someone named solid snake
and it kind of merges the last two
questions so
broadly speaking this individual was
going to get surgery
and it was a hernia repair surgery wait
first tricks do you know who solid snake
is
no okay uh so
that's a video game reference he was the
protagonist of the metal gear solid
franchise
okay um just the way you said that name
suggested to me that you uh
you had no knowledge of one of the most
iconic video game characters ever so i i
just wanted to check that to be sure
yeah perhaps i haven't made that clear
if it's about a movie
a tv show a video game really anything
related to society
or culture i don't i don't know about it
i don't get it yeah fair enough
um all right so
this video game character is getting a
hernia repair surgery
uh not allowed to exercise for a given
amount of time
surgeon wasn't really given clear
updates basically just said hey you
can't lift anything over 30 pounds for
like three or four weeks
uh so the question is what do i do about
this
how quickly should i expect to recover
when can i start lifting again
and on top of that they ask what can i
do to make sure i don't lose my gains
during that time period specifically
as it pertains to nutritional strategies
so like i said with the nutritional
strategies part
the dietary stuff just isn't that
efficacious
there have been studies looking at
higher protein approaches they don't
work
that well you know you pretty much
lose the muscle if you're not activating
the muscle and loading it providing
that tension the few studies that do
report some promising effects
uh give somewhere around 15 to 19 grams
per day
of leucine which is a lot of leucine
on top of you know the the typical diet
uh so those studies use essential amino
acids or just
you know isolated leucine supplements to
give
pretty big doses uh throughout the day
and a lot of the protein studies or the
lower dose
leucine studies where the individuals
are only getting 10
uh grams per day or less of extra
leucine
they really just don't seem to be
efficacious so if i had to put my money
on
maybe something that could partially
attenuate
uh some of the detraining
losses of muscle mass that might occur
maybe adopting a high protein diet with
some pretty generous
additional leucine supplementation that
would be my
my best guess but like i said i i really
don't
have high hopes for that that strategy i
think it
when it comes to maintaining muscle mass
and strength you just got to load the
tissue
unfortunately now
another question uh was about you know
the specific timeline to return
the retraining process and things like
that like i said
if you're interested in maintaining
muscle and strength any amount of
safe and tolerable muscle loading is
going to be far superior to none
but the specific timeline for recovery
is really variable and it's the type of
thing where you really have to rely on
your medical
professionals to to give you
contextualized answers to your questions
and you might have to bother them a
little bit and say can i do this can i
do that
they're likely to to err on the
conservative side but
one of the things to keep in mind i know
a lot of people struggle with this
issue where they want to train through
something that maybe they shouldn't
train through
for for a period of time you know like
you have a surgery and they say hey for
two weeks for four weeks you gotta let
everything heal up so that you don't
undo what we did surgically and then you
know we have
all sorts of problems on our hands so uh
people struggle with that a lot and it's
really critical to remember that
retraining
is a pretty quick process like when you
get back into training after a layoff uh
those gains are pretty easy to come by
at first
so psychologically take some comfort in
that
you know don't don't try to rush it and
whenever i'm working with a client and
they want to train through something
whether it's a medical procedure or
you know a small injury or something
like that
what's the one phrase like an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
yeah when it comes to training through
stuff
sometimes just taking your foot off the
gas pedal and
really emphasizing the short-term
recovery
is such a better payoff over time you
know and if you try to train through it
and you nag it and you nag it and you
continue to aggravate it
you you create a really long-term
annoyance
that it would have been much better to
just handle it on the front end
fully recover get back into it phase in
your training logically
uh conservatively and you just set
yourself up for a much smoother process
you get yourself back to 100 quicker so
my general advice of course was specific
timing there's no way i'm going to tell
you oh her
hernia surgery here's how many weeks
like i i'm not qualified to do that
it would be reckless for me to do that
but you got to have a good nuanced
conversation with your medical
professional and you
you should err on the side of caution
just to make sure that you fully recover
and heal
and you don't create a long-term problem
out of a short-term problem
yeah and just to toss something in there
since since i know we have a global
audience and that
uh expression eric used may not be
familiar to everyone an ounce of
prevention is worth a pound of cure
for our listeners outside of the u.s
that is
28.3 grams of prevention is worth 0.454
kilograms of cure
uh so i hope that clears things up yeah
that actually is a better way to present
it when you put it that way
okay david allen asks these may be dumb
questions but for lifters who have
increasingly sporadic sleep schedules
through no fault of their own what are
some things to actually increase
performance
recovery and body composition are
specific
lengths of naps helpful or is it just
a matter of waiting until the next long
slumber
should you ever exercise while exhausted
or sleep deprived
yeah so um in general
uh there i mean so that this relates to
uh the first question i answered as well
unfortunately there's not great research
uh about the longitudinal effects of not
sleeping
enough on uh especially performance and
hypertrophy based outcomes
um so as far as it goes for
body composition um not sleeping enough
does tend to increase weight gain
and fat gain likely through
probably two dominant mechanisms one is
just self-control
decreases when you're sleep deprived and
so uh
in appetite regulation gets screwed up
so
you probably just end up eating more and
have a hard
a harder time keeping yourself from
eating more
but then two there's also some research
showing that
your body's preferential fuel sources
shift a little bit so you go from
at rest burning predominantly fat to
burning a slightly higher
proportion of carbohydrate and protein
which
is also independently probably not a
great thing for
long-term body comp outcomes um
but i mean as far as as far as stuff
like that goes
you know it's easy to just say like
have more self-control um but there are
little things that you could do
uh in your life to
maybe not require quite as much
self-control if you're interested in
this from a body comp perspective
the biggest is is probably just not
having
especially high calorie hyper palatable
foods
in the house and easily accessible
because i mean
you can overeat chicken breast and
potatoes and white rice and
scrambled eggs and whatever else but you
know
if your self-control is nil because
you're super sleep deprived
it's hard to fall too far off the wagon
if those are
the options you have available to
overeat um so you know that's
a simple little thing you can do just
try to shift your food environment a
little bit
to make it harder to
fall entirely off the wagon if
you know if self-control decreases
because you're very sleep-deprived
when it comes to recovery and
performance
i mean i think the same basic rules
still apply
something that improves recovery when
you are not sleep deprived
will probably still improve cover
recovery if you are
sleep deprived so water immersion
probably helps
compression garments probably help
massage probably helps to some degree i
mean just
little things like that active recovery
going for a walk
walks are still great if you're sleep
deprived
honestly i kind of love walks when i'm
sleep deprived because
you kind of feel like you're you're
swimming through a strange unreality and
i think it's pretty sick
um yeah i mean you know
anything that enhances recovery probably
enhances recovery independent of
whether you're sleep deprived or not uh
and then then when it comes to
performance and muscle specifically
uh the question asks you know should you
ever exercise while exhausted or sleep
deprived
i think the two biggest considerations
there are
one if you're very sleep deprived
it's probably not a great idea to do
a lot of cardiovascular activity outside
if it's very hot
because thermoregulation can be impaired
if you're very sleep deprived
and if you're sleep deprived enough that
it
is significantly affecting
your motor control it may not be a great
idea
to do really heavy or really high
speed free weight stuff so you know
may not be a great idea to go for a max
squat
or a max clean and jerk or something
like that or even like
really heavy or like fairly heavy and
like really close to failure type stuff
if it's the type of thing where a
lapse in motor control and losing
control of the bar
could have really negative consequences
maybe that's not the best option of
things to do when sleep deprived
and there's also there's evidence
in team sport athletes that
non-contact soft tissue injury rates are
higher
when when athletes aren't sleeping
enough
and that probably relates to some degree
to lack of motor control as well so
you know uh any sort of exercise that
any sort of exercise slash loading
combination
that has a reasonably high chance
of maybe causing a muscle strain
or something like that maybe not the
best idea to do when you're really sleep
deprived
but what should be quite safe to do
and what you can absolutely do and
should do
i would say if if you're interested
especially in muscle based outcomes
is just lighter kind of bodybuilder
style training
hop on some machines grab some dumbbells
don't do anything super heavy
like like uh trek said in answering
another question
ultimately resistance training is the
primary stimulus for muscle and
everything else is a distant second
one thing to note is that surveys
of elite athletes in really pretty much
every sport
suggest that most elite athletes don't
sleep nearly as much
as sleep experts would recommend um
and i mean like a relatively sizable
minority average
less than six hours per night like it
very well could be that that like yeah
maybe if you're
for whatever reason in a situation where
you can only get like two hours per
night
who knows maybe you're just kind of dead
in the water uh but
when most people talk about like oh i
have a sporadic sleep schedule
you know they may be talking about
occasional all-nighters
nights that they occasionally get four
or five hours per sleep and maybe can
sleep more other nights
kind of averaging out to five or six
hours of sleep per night
a lot of very very successful athletes
do sleep that little which is not ideal
but you know they're still able to train
and make gains so
you know i i would prioritize safety
again because motor control will
probably be compromised to some degree
um but yeah like bodybuilt bodybuilding
style training
especially on machines um
where just any sort of exercise where
the
uh where the consequence of losing
control of the implement
is relatively minor yeah
you're probably good to go so uh
yeah that's that's what i'd recommend
this question also asked about naps
um and yeah if you're really sleep
deprived naps can be helpful
i i think that's one of those things
where it's good to just
know yourself and know how naps impact
your ability to sleep at night so some
people if you take a nap through the day
that's longer than say 20 minutes
that can negatively impact your ability
to fall asleep and stay asleep
uh the upcoming night and if that
happens maybe the naps are doing more
harm than good
but especially if you are again quite
sleep deprived
that probably won't happen and if you
know from experience like hey
i can i can get a sleep cycle and i can
take a 90-minute nap
i feel better when i wake up and it
doesn't negatively impact my sleep
uh the next night then yeah you can you
can get a longer nap in and otherwise
like
uh i i think a lot of people do
recommend
shorter naps just to kind of refresh
yourself
so you know somewhere in the 20 to 30
minute range that that should be
uh pretty pretty tolerable for most
people in most contexts
but yeah in general i mean keep training
and
and choose exercises that are
particularly safe i would say yeah there
is some evidence we've covered it in
mass a few times recently
there's some evidence that those short
naps can have
a positive effect acutely on performance
in participants who have been restricted
of their sleep so you know the
experimental intervention
uh requires participants to have very
short sleep
a nap before exercise performance can be
a positive thing but like you said
it'd be really nice to see the those
types of studies
take a multiple day approach where we
then see how does that affect their
sleep that night
and that that would give a little bit of
a better assessment of the
overall pros and cons of that napping
strategy but
uh but yeah if you're listening to this
and you're thinking but just to get me
through this next workout should i nap
or not
if we're viewing it in a vacuum you know
in isolation there is some of the
evidence there to suggest that napping
can be a pretty helpful strategy
um okay moving on to the next question
i've got one from
toby c how do you spell keith
with a c or a k might be toby keith uh
it's okay
i know i'm kidding uh yeah not what's
toby's last name on the office
i have no idea okay so either uh
talking i'll get this yeah it could be
an office character could be a country
music legend we don't know but toby c
uh had a question about training hard
it's flinderson
oh that's not it so the question
is uh how do we define training hard
um and
then there's a bunch of other stuff but
that's pretty much the question
how hard is is hard enough when it comes
to training
um and this is something i you were on
jeff nippard's channel talking about
this recently um but
i haven't listened to that yet what i
know i
i figured i could just consume all of
the content that i put out
i i don't unbelievable i haven't yet but
i
i enjoy your content and i enjoy jeff
very much so i'll get to it very soon
uh but i'd love to hear your answer uh
after i
uh take a stab at it here so i think
there are a few ways to look at
training hard and i'm going to answer
this from
the uh you know not not the assumption
that you want to
you know go in nationals and
powerlifting but you know just
the typical trainee who wants to maybe
get stronger
improve body composition stuff like that
so so the first thing to consider is
your proximity to failure i think that's
one variable that often comes up when we
have this discussion of
how hard should i train and you know
coming from a bodybuilding background
it can be really hard to convince people
that they will be okay
if they train with an rir of one
or maybe two but uh but you know we
shouldn't always it's those reps
past failure that yeah that really give
you the gains
yeah the the typical bodybuilding rp is
about an or
rir i should say is about a negative
five like you should get
those five reps where your spotter is
just pulling the bar off of your chest
um
but no so i i usually like to keep my
reps and reserve values
between zero and four uh when i'm
getting after it on a d
load i might go uh higher than four of
course
but in my my real training weeks
uh when i'm doing my working sets i like
my reps and reserve values to be
zero to four approximately meaning i
have somewhere between zero and four
repetitions
left in the tank when i terminate the
set
uh and i like to ramp up my compound
exercises so at the beginning of a
training block my reps and reserve
values might be around a three or four
and then as the training block
progresses i work a little bit closer to
failure i do some more twos and some
ones and sometimes i get pretty close to
failure
depending on the exercise you know some
exercises i never really push them that
close to failure
but with plenty of exercises you can do
that uh with a high confidence level
that
you know you're not going to hurt
yourself or do anything that's unsafe or
anything like that
so uh another thing to consider aside
from proximity to failure is
the overall amount of volume that you're
doing within a program
and i i usually you know start out with
making sure i have
enough volume just to make sure that i
keep my gains moving
forward continuing to make strides in
the right direction and sometimes
you've got a sufficient amount of volume
you notice that your your gains are
starting to taper off a little bit
but you know you're not really you know
at your genetic
ceiling at your limit and you say okay
might be time to incorporate a little
bit more total training volume
into the training week here um and
you know what what i tend to find is for
for a lot of people at first
we can keep pushing pretty well uh with
with a pretty
low to moderate amount of volume a very
tolerable amount of volume
keeping those reps in reserve uh in that
zero to four range
and we can extend some pretty long
training blocks before we feel like we
really have to take a de-load
and rest up and dive into the next
training block
but usually once you get past your kind
of introductory phase to lifting
if your reps and reserves are staying
between zero and four
if you've got enough volume to keep
things moving forward a lot of times
you'll tend to find
that you do need a deload from time to
time you know you just start to
accumulate some of that fatigue
subjectively over time and
you can kind of feel like yeah i'm
pretty beat up i'm pretty fatigued here
i've been pushing it hard for a while
i need to take a a deload here rest up
for a week and then start a new block of
training
uh and so a lot of times when i'm
talking with
intermediate or advanced trainees if
they're like you know what i'm
i'm keeping my reps and reserve values
in the right range
um but things seem really stagnant in
terms of my gains
you know sometimes i'll i'll pry a
little bit and see like how frequently
do you feel like you really need a
deload
and sometimes the answer is like almost
never
and i think it can be helpful to
experiment with maybe
ramping up the training volume in that
scenario and seeing if maybe you just
weren't
doing enough and you had a little bit
you know you you could have pushed a
little bit more
on a week-to-week basis um but it's hard
to say
exactly how much volume a person needs
but sometimes i do like to experiment
with cranking things up a little bit
and what we'll find is oh yeah a little
more volume
allowed me to tap into some better gains
here but
after five or six weeks of that i did
feel like i needed a deload
that probably means that we weren't
quite doing enough and maybe needed to
do a little bit
more and that's going to change over
time as your training status changes as
a lifter so
it's hard to give a really tight concise
answer to that question but
that's my approach to proximity to
failure and also my approach to just the
overall
amount of training that we're doing in
the program
yeah i would say uh the only real
scientific answer here is uh harder than
last time
uh and that's that's all i got perfect
is that what you told jeff
uh that's that's yeah something that's
what a
a greg told him uh no i
i largely agree with what you said um
yeah i think that in general um
your your body's feedback is what tells
you
how hard you're training uh and the the
threshold for what
you know might be considered hard is
probably different for different people
i think that there's there's feedback
you can get when you're done with a
training session
and also over time so as far as overtime
goes
i i largely agree with what trek said i
think that
um you know if you never feel like you
need a deload
you probably can be training a bit
harder if you feel like
you need to deload after two weeks of
training
you're probably pushing it too hard but
you know if you're training with a given
level of
rep reps in reserve and total training
volume
and you feel like you need a deload
every
maybe four to eight weeks give or take
you know
you're just kind of training along and
after a round of that period of time
you're like yeah
i'm feeling a little worn down i
probably need to take it easy for a week
i think that's a good indication that
your training is generally hard enough
and on a shorter time scale i think when
you
when you leave the gym you can get
valuable feedback from that as well
if you feel like you just you know need
to peel yourself off the floor
um and when you're walking out to the
parking lot you're
you're thinking to yourself i really
don't know that i'm safe to drive right
now
uh you probably pushed it a little bit
too hard
uh but if you're still completely fresh
and you know you're leaving the gym with
more energy than you
entered it with uh you probably didn't
train
hard enough to be clear there are times
you would want to do that like
if you're doing an active recovery
session or something like that
uh or even just like during a deload
week ideally you do want to leave the
gym
feeling better than you did when you
entered it um
but you probably shouldn't be doing
active recovery or deload style training
for
90 of your training so uh yeah
if you're if you're feeling fatigued um
your performance is has obviously
decreased
but it hasn't fallen off a cliff and you
don't feel like
again you have to just be peeled off the
floor of the gym
uh that's i think a pretty decent
indication that your
your training is appropriate i also
think sleep is a pretty good indicator
um this is purely subjective but i think
that
if you're training if if when you're
training
your sleep is better you fall asleep
easier
you feel like you're sleeping more
soundly you're waking up feeling
refreshed
i think that's a pretty good indication
that the
overall intensity and difficulty of your
training is
is probably appropriate um
if it's negatively impacting your sleep
you're probably pushing it a little bit
too hard so i think that just kind of
subjective assessment of sleep uh is
another
pretty decent indicator of of how hard
you're training
i didn't even think of the sleep one but
that's a good one um because yeah
i i've noticed my sleep is really
sensitive if i'm not training i sleep
like crap
if i'm training well i sleep great but
then if i push it a little too much it
starts to impair sleep a little bit
one caveat though i agree with
everything you said but
if you are a physique athlete late in
prep
none of that stuff applies anymore
because like
when i'm like really late in prep i have
to peel myself
off of every surface to do every task in
the day
like so peeling yourself off the gym
floor like late in prep is
probably going to be the reality uh
unfortunately and sleep disruption is
absolutely going to be the reality
yeah i mean i'm talking about like
normal healthy adults
yes i classify being four weeks out from
a physique show as a
physiologically pathological condition
it is yeah yeah absolutely
uh yeah no i just wanted to uh what i
don't want to see is you know
a bunch of people who are like doing a
bodybuilding prep who are like oh i
listened to this podcast and it said if
i feel
lethargic i should train less and like
no you're you're lethargic because
uh you know you're five percent body fat
so
i just wanted to throw that in there for
all the the bodybuilders
listening along uh okay greg you've got
one from
evan gleaves here i do so evan asks uh
if and this is this is one that uh i
think you would probably have good
feedback on as well
so just for for uh complete transparency
my process of selecting questions to
answer
in q a segments of the podcast is i i
post
threads both in the stronger by science
community
facebook group and the stronger by
science subreddit
and unless there's just a really really
dumb question
uh i just snag the most highly liked or
upvoted questions
um and so this one i think is probably
more in trex's wheelhouse but
you know i'm trying to give the people
what they want so i'll take a swipe at
it
so evan asks if you find yourself at
your calorie goal for the day but way
below your protein goal
should you eat the extra calories to get
your protein or avoid
or avoid going over your calorie goal by
hundreds
uh what if this happens often exclude
obvious situations like a dream or bulk
so basically um you know if you have a
calorie allotment you're trying to hit
for the day
and you also have a protein goal you're
trying to hit for the day and you hit
your calorie goal
uh well before you hit your protein goal
should you just eat more protein
to meet your protein goal if that
also involves going over your calorie
goal so i
i think first and foremost and this
question also asks
what if this is happening frequently so
i think first and foremost
the like the the big brain approach
is to try to make sure it's not
happening frequently so
you know if you're say if your calorie
goals are so low
that to eat a diet you find at all
palatable
uh you're consuming enough fat and carbs
that you're hitting your
your calorie goal well before your
protein goal um
you know that might suggest that your
total calorie intake is
so low that you're just gonna have a
really really tough time sticking to the
diet so
if if it's really low because you're in
a big
calorie deficit maybe try cutting at a
slower rate so you can just get some
more calories in your diet
and have an easier time hitting your
protein goal while
staying within your calorie allotment
for the day uh
or you know it may be a matter of
changing
the foods you're eating or like food
behavior so
you know if if something like that is
happening often
because you know maybe you're not
meal prepping and you know not everyone
has to meal prep but
i think that's a common strategy just
because it does make
eating well uh
more frictionless i guess because you
already have stuff that more or less
meets your macros ready to go
or you know maybe you're just not
planning ahead particularly well so
uh you're not say packing a lunch when
you go to work
and then when it's lunch time you could
either
drive 20 minutes to a place that makes
some healthy food and get that or you
could get something
less healthy out of a vending machine or
not necessarily less healthy but just
you know higher carbs higher fat less
protein
that could be a situation that you could
remedy just by planning a little bit
better and
and maybe packing your lunch so you know
look to see
one that your total calorie goal is
appropriate and something that you you
have a decent chance of being
able to stick to uh two if the
total calorie target isn't uh
inappropriately low
look at some of those other behaviors
food environment type things and try to
modify
those so that you do have a better
chance of
meeting your protein goal uh before your
calorie goal
three make sure your protein intake uh
target
is something that's pretty feasible so
you know
if uh i think like the
kind of standard middle of the range uh
protein goal that most people tell you
to aim for
is somewhere around 1.6 grams of protein
per kilogram of body mass
which you know can scale up higher
certainly if you're in a calorie deficit
but if you're someone who has just
always eaten really high protein and
maybe your protein target is like 2.5
grams per kilo or something like that
maybe just bring your protein target
down
and then it's going to be more more
feasible to hit
on a daily basis so you know if
if your protein intake is absurdly high
and you're having a hard time
hitting it before you go over your your
calorie alignment for the day
and there's some wiggle room on the on
the lower end where you can drop it from
2.4 2.5 to 1.6 1.7
and maybe drop it to 1.6 1.7 um
so anyway on the front end
before even addressing the question look
to make sure that that your
uh your eating behavior and your macro
targets and total calorie targets are
things that are
feasible and will be doable
most of the time if they're not doable
most of the time if this is a problem
that you're consistently running into
i would say the issue is more of that
back end stuff
uh either inappropriate calorie targets
and appropriate protein targets or just
um food and eating behaviors that are
going to make sticking with any diet
pretty challenging
uh so assuming all of that is taken care
of and it's just a one-time situation
so or you know something that maybe
happens once a week but not
crazy frequently you've you've hit your
calorie goal for the day but you
have protein left over what do you do do
you eat more protein
even if that means going over your
calorie goal so i think
ultimately if it's something that
happens very rarely
like you know once a month or something
like that
it doesn't matter it'll be fine either
way you go over your calories by 200 for
a day
uh over the course of a multi-week
multi-month diet
you're not even going to notice that or
if you fall way below
your protein goal one day it's also not
going to make that much of a difference
so if it's something that's happening
very rarely
just be chill you know that
that would be my recommendation if it's
something that is happening somewhat
more frequently
then i think it's worth keeping your
overall goals in mind
so you know if if you're
in a calorie deficit my
kind of default knee jerk reaction is
that like
you do need the protein to help maintain
lean mass uh and unless you're just in a
super super super con conservative
deficit uh
i i think there's probably more wiggle
room and a lower cost
of going a little bit over your calories
one day to make sure you're getting an
adequate protein so you know let's say
you're trying to lose a pound a week
a cumulative calorie deficit of about 3
500 calories
if you have to go over 200 calories one
day to hit your protein target
and so now your cumulative weekly
deficit is 3 300 calories
that'll be fine uh i think in a
situation like that
it probably does make more sense to go
over a little bit to try to hit your
protein goal
um if you're in a surplus
uh it kind of just depends on what your
philosophy is there if
you know if you're kind of doing a dirty
bulk like whatever what's another couple
hundred calories to your protein goal
if you're trying to do more of a like
quote-unquote lean bulk
um you know you're already in a surplus
protein's not quite as precious
you know maybe stay 30 40 grams under
your protein target
and don't go crazy with the calories but
again ultimately i think that this is
more indicative of a bigger problem
because like i said if if this is
something that only happens
once in a blue moon like once a month
say
it's really not gonna matter you can go
either way you won't it's not gonna
it's not gonna make that much of a
difference if it's something that is
happening
pretty frequently then
look at total calorie intake look at
total protein intake
look at your approach to dieting your
approach to eating and
make make adjustments or corrections at
that level
to make sure that this isn't a problem
that comes up frequently
yeah i agree that uh the biggest point
is
if it's super rare it probably doesn't
matter and if it's super common
uh no answer here is going to be
sufficient you have to address the the
root of that problem
but for stuff in the middle my
perspective differs a little bit
you know i think one of the most
frustrating things working with
one-on-one clients
is when a client says man i've been
sticking to this diet for a long time
and the scale's just not moving in the
right direction
you know it's not going at the the rate
i was hoping
uh so i i try to avoid that as much as i
can
even if it's at the expense of having
lower protein for a day or two here or
there i try to make sure
you know if i'm working with somebody
and the the goal
unequivocally without question is
losing weight and fat mass over time
i try to make sure that we maintain our
deficit as consistently as we can
so it's just two different ways of
looking at the same
conundrum which is something's got to
give here
and what i usually i usually kind of
classify it based on what goal is most
pressing at the moment and so if if
we're doing a really
focused weight loss phase then i say you
know what
one day of protein being a little bit
lower like i'm assuming we're not
talking about yeah i'm
i'm at 30 of my protein recommendation
for today like if we're getting up to
70 80 of what we were supposed to get
i'm i'm pretty comfortable saying let's
keep our deficit where it is we'll go a
little lower on the protein today
we'll live to fight another day and you
know we see people who
uh you know as fasting becomes more
more common and more uh popularized
we see people who go a full day without
protein
if relatively frequently and it's not
not my ideal
approach to nutrition but you know it
they're okay
i mean you can get away with having a
low protein day here and there
same thing goes on the other side of the
spectrum if i've got somebody who
they're like listen i don't care if i
gain a little fat here but i need
to support hypertrophy by any means
necessary
for that particular individual i say
well then fine obviously that the
conclusion is very simple get your
protein in if we go over calories it's
no big deal
the tricky scenario in my mind is the
person who's in between who's trying to
get the best of both worlds who
maybe is trying to bulk in a really lean
way
or maybe is trying to recomp it's trying
to lose some fat as they gain muscle
and they want the best of both worlds
what i would say for that individual
is maybe consider splitting the
difference right so if you're way off
your protein goal for the day
and getting to your protein goal is
going to you know put you 200 250
calories over
what if we eat our way up to about 85 90
percent of our protein target for the
day and just kind of split the
difference so instead of hitting the
target
and going 250 over we get closer to the
target but we don't go
quite as far over on our calories so
there there is a middle ground there
where you could say you know what
let's hit 85 90 of the protein target
with the leanest protein source we can
find
and we've learned a good lesson and
tomorrow we'll go about our meal
planning a little bit differently
so you know your perspective was a
little bit different than mine
neither is inherently more correct it
really comes down to
what is the absolute top
priority right and so for for you you
have a great point that
if someone's in a big deficit we have to
be extra mindful
of lean mass losses right so you you
could very easily justify saying hey we
got to get that protein in and one
higher calorie day
whatever we'll call it a refeed we're
good to go so there's no
better or worse right or wrong here it's
just a matter of perspective
and how we stack those priorities and
i tell you what if i'm working with
somebody who's dieting
and they're they really want to lose
weight but they are obsessive about
we cannot lose an ounce of muscle on
this cut i'm going with your approach uh
you know the that
i'm just going to say get your protein
in we'll have a higher calorie day
so it depends on the goal and i mean
it's ultimately a matter of
making sure that this is a sometimes
conundrum
other rather than an often conundrum
absolutely yeah so it shouldn't be
something that's a big problem
it shouldn't be recurring regularly and
so by definition
whichever strategy you take shouldn't be
critical because we're talking about
a couple days a month where this really
comes up yeah
if you're overall adhering pretty well
and this is a rare thing there are
really no bad options
uh and if it's coming up all the time
there are really no good options
yeah absolutely yeah okay
um i've got a question from
i love greg eric one of my favorite
listeners to be honest
uh the question is how do you employ
periodization for the compound lifts to
enhance
uh bodybuilding progress
um so this is a good question i think my
answer
might maybe surprise some people but i
don't think that really sophisticated
periodization is critical
for bodybuilding purposes um
and you know you have to manage your
training variables
so like you know there is some nuance to
the programming to some extent
but i don't think it's really critical
to have this kind of
52-week plan where you're
really drastically altering these
variables because
the goal is pretty uh pretty
straightforward right we if you're a
bodybuilder you probably don't need a
whole phase of training that's focused
on you know
building strength in the eccentric phase
of lifts you probably don't need a whole
phase of training that's dedicated to
uh you know increasing explosive power
uh at high velocities of contraction
like
the goal is to build muscle and so
pretty much
across the year 52 weeks a year we're
trying to
uh apply tension to the muscle to help
it grow and do that in a way that is
basically efficient and not excessively
time consuming or burdensome
yeah i mean when you look at uh like
rationales for periodization
it's gener the whole concept is
basically like okay
let's break down what the needs are for
a particular sport
what training aims we're trying to
accomplish and split things up into
blocks that can help us accomplish each
of those aims in a
logical sequential pattern and one of
the aims that a lot of athletes and a
lot of sports will have is like hey in
the off season let's try to build some
muscle
so okay you're going to have a block
dedicated to
hypertrophy training with you know other
things taking a backseat and
only being sprinkled in here and there
but if you think about bodybuilding
training
uh you know first
first month of the year uh or of or of
your
competition cycle what's the goal of
that block gonna be
hypertrophy okay okay so we're done with
our hypertrophy mesocycle
next mesocycle what uh what
what are we gonna build on that
hypertrophy block uh
to logically move forward in a sequence
of training blocks
oh we're gonna do more hypertrophy
because that's the whole that's the
whole [ __ ] sport
so uh i i feel like if you asked this
to a bodybuilding.com writer in 2008
uh or a uh
a big time like nsca devotee they would
have a
very long answer for you and i feel like
if you ask this to
a periodization theorist like you know
if you hit up
vladimir siren and said hey how should i
periodize my training for bodybuilding
they'd probably just laugh at you
because they'd be like bodybuilding's
not a sport you don't have multiple
physical capacities you're trying to
develop
you're trying to get big uh why
periodize
yeah yeah so i mean but like i said you
still have to manage your training
variables you're not just going to like
put together a block of train
and say i'm gonna do this for the next
75 weeks
right so as i've stated previously
in this episode keeping the reps and
reserve values between zero and four
generally ramping them down as you go
so increasing your proximity to failure
especially for the compound lifts you
probably don't have to be as aggressive
with
you know having high reps in reserve for
your isolation work early in a block
tricep extensions bicep curls lateral
raises you can probably push those
relatively close to failure even early
in the training block
and not have to really move them around
too much but you know
if you're training hard with the right
amount of volume
every month every two months maybe every
third month
you're going to need a deload at some
point you know whether it's at 4 6
8 10 weeks probably going to need a
deload
and after your deload you're probably
going to notice that some programming
variables require changing
so during your last training block maybe
you improved some weak areas that you
were focusing on and so now the
uh the squeaky wheel that needs more
attention has changed from block to
block
and you might shift emphasis to
something else
i know that was my big thing before i
did my first competition i was like
i just need one more training block to
get my chest bigger and then i'll be
ready to go
and it would work and then i'd be like
well one more training block to bring up
my lats and then i'll be ready
but you can see block to block that that
thing changes and it can be a pretty
if that's the thing that's delaying you
from competing you may never compete
that was the cycle i was getting in but
um anyway you're going to see that
different areas need emphasis you're
going to change your training around
you might have some staleness lack of
varieties that might cause you to tweak
some perform
some some training variables which is
totally justifiable you should enjoy
your training if you're not enjoying it
you probably ought to be changing
something to make sure that you enjoy it
more
unless you're a professional athlete and
you just gotta get your training in
there is some argument about whether or
not adding in some strength work here
and there
might have benefit for hypertrophy um
that research greg i know you've written
about it in mass what's your current
take should a bodybuilder have
a focused strength block i am a strength
skeptic
okay skeptical of the concept of
strength
but yeah so some people say oh a
bodybuilder you got to alternate between
strength focused phases and hypertrophy
focused phases
probably not but if you find the
strength focused phases to be enjoyable
you can configure them in a way that is
absolutely very suitable for hypertrophy
you know you
just have to tweak your set and rep
schemes a little bit
um it might not be the most time
efficient way to train but
you can do some strength work in a way
that still has a great hypertrophy
stimulus if you
design it appropriately now when it
comes to periodization
the one area where i think you could
make an argument
is when you're transitioning from the
off season
into prep i think you could argue not
necessarily that the training goals
change but
that your physical capacity for training
changes a little bit
so deeper into a prep cardio
is likely to be increased or physical
you know non-lifting physical activity
that's something that might be factored
into your management of resistance
training variables
and another thing that factors in is
that you're going to be in a big caloric
deficit
low body fat probably low carbohydrate
especially toward the end and so you
might
trend toward some higher intensity lower
volume work
later in that that process
you might alter your repetition scheme
so that they're not
squarely in the the glycolytic sweet
spot
um and this is you know there's not
strong direct evidence for these
exact uh alterations to your training
but
from a practical perspective if you're
really glycogen depleted as just
a constant state because of your dietary
demands
uh and you're noticing that you thought
you could do 15 reps and after
eight you're just done it might be an
indicator that you should focus a little
more effort on some of the
uh lower repetition schemes and just
stop trying to fight an energy system
battle that you are not equipped to win
at that point in time so
later in a prep i do drop a little bit
of my accessory work because of the
additional cardio and physical activity
i drop some of my extra sets uh i
i start to lean toward or gravitate
towards some higher loads with uh
with lower repetition numbers um just to
make sure that your training is
compatible with
what you're physically and
physiologically ready to to actually
handle you you want to
you want to mitigate uh the potential
downsides of the the restriction that
you're doing you want to make sure that
you're
altering your programming variables to
to really adequately match what you're
fueled to do in the gym
and what you have the ability to recover
from so that that's really the extent
of what i would consider periodization
as it pertains to to bodybuilding
makes sense to me all right uh your
reindeer we're we're moving from
facebook to reddit
your reindeer asks uh if ethics and
money
were no concern what's a study you'd
love to see
um so there were comments under this uh
anticipating that i would take this to a
very dark place
so i'm going to start by giving the
people what they want and then i'm going
to give my real answer
which isn't a particularly dark answer
so uh the dark answer
if um an open
question which i think i lean against
scientific consensus on an open question
is whether skeletal muscle hyperplasia
occurs in humans
and the reason that's an open question
is the way you go about studying
hyperplasia in
animals and so by the way uh
just terminology hypertrophy is the
growth
of muscle fibers and hyperplasia is
adding more muscle fibers and it's
commonly believed that in humans
hyperplasia doesn't occur
at least during adulthood
and the increase in in skeletal muscle
size
due to resistance training is due purely
to skeletal muscle hypertrophy
the reason i think hyperplasia occurs in
humans
is it has it occurs in every
other animal we've tried to find it in
uh
happens in birds happens in cats happens
in mice
uh when we do anything that resembles a
resistance training stimulus
in other vertebrates uh skeletal muscle
hyperplasia occurs
i really just don't see a good reason
why it wouldn't occur in humans but
it hasn't been observed and the reason
it hasn't been observed is
there's really not a good way to count
muscle fibers
with uh with the muscle intact and so
in animals what that means is you put
them through some sort of
protocol maybe it's something mimicking
resistance training maybe it's weighted
stretching in the case of the bird
studies
um and then you euthanize the animal
you remove the muscle and you count the
fibers
you can't really do that in humans
because ethics
are a thing um but i mean
you know if the people want me to take
it dark
you could do this in humans without
killing the humans by finding people
who would be willing to volunteer to
have a limb amputated for the sake of
science or just have a
muscle completely excised for the sake
of science
uh where you know you have some people
they do some training uh
you know maybe like calf training
possibly just so it's not going to
impact their activities of daily living
too too much
uh you know take the leg at the knee
and then see whether the the total
number of calf fibers has increased
and this also asks if money was no
concern
money would definitely be a concern for
that study because
it apparently takes hours and hours and
hours to count
fibers in just like a tiny little muscle
and mice
if you're counting every muscle fiber in
a human gastroc
whoo buddy good [ __ ] luck especially
if you have a
a reasonable sample size so anyway that
would be a very unethical study that
would
allow you to get a pretty definitive
answer to
what is at the moment an open question
and seems like it will be an open
question for the foreseeable future
uh in terms of whether hyperplasia
occurs in humans
um in terms of what i would actually
want to see
probably my number one a study is i
would just want to see
a very very intense exploratory study
where you have
a really really big sample size um
ideally you'd uh include
twins and you'd have siblings and you'd
have people in similar families
you could look at some genetic stuff uh
i'd like to see a within subject
unilateral design
and maybe like multiple different sets
of training programs used in people
because
again i'm assuming we have a sample size
in the hundreds at least
and so you know maybe you can test a
grand total of
eight programs or four sets of two
programs to see
uh variability in individual responses
to different training stimuli
um and just collect all of the data all
of it
uh look at genetic stuff look at
epigenetic stuff
look at protein markers look at gene
expression
um look at metabolomics i heard that i
mispronounced that in a previous episode
i said metabolomics
uh i've never heard that word said
before i'd only read it
that is my excuse but yeah just
just everything um because currently
uh we we still don't know
in detail down to just like the finest
nittiest grittiest detail um
all of the processes that bring about
and influence muscle growth and strength
gains
and you know ultimately i think if we
had a full mechanistic
understanding of that entire process
that would help
guide future research to make it
better and to help people ask
more interesting questions that maybe at
the moment with our current knowledge we
wouldn't even think to ask
so i i think just like a massive massive
exploratory study where you can just
throw everything in the kitchen sink at
it to
learn more about mechanisms and
generate more hypotheses based on just
the sheer amount of data you're able to
gather
look for things that might mediate
whether someone responds to one style of
training better versus another style of
training
i think that that would just move the
whole field forward 20 years
and so that that is honestly the the
type of study that i'd like to see
if uh if money were no concern how about
you trex
uh my only feedback is that
when we ventured out into this space of
creating audio content
the one challenge that i didn't even
think of
was the fact that so many of the words i
use in my brain
i have only read and never heard
[Laughter]
exactly the same so many of the words i
use in my writing
i have read and never actually heard
um and i i was fully unprepared for that
which is why we mispronounce almost
every word on our podcast
maybe other people are using these words
but i i don't consume a lot of content
uh and so yeah i have no idea how to say
anything that's in my mind which is a
really hard place to be
yeah it'll shock you to hear dear
listener that
when the mics aren't rolling me and trex
aren't just like sitting around talking
about metabolomics
we are not um all right
moving on i've got oh do you not have a
a dream study
um i feel like this was a question for
both of us
dream study uh well i agree with your
general approach that i think
if we're trying to get a lot of bang for
our buck a big exploratory study that is
really well conducted would be great
um one study that i would really love to
see
uh i might as well just there's two very
small questions
that uh have been bothering me for a
while
um actually i'll give three first of all
uh the creatine caffeine interaction uh
there was a study
just a couple months ago that i covered
in mass that was perfectly designed to
address it
uh but covid really threw a wrench in
the plan and
the sample size just wasn't there but
it's one of those questions where
the general consensus is don't worry
about it and that consensus
is absolutely not based on the data that
have been provided to date
and if you want a nuanced take on how i
feel about it stronger by science.com
creatine i have a whole section kind of
detailing um
my views on it another one is
i think there's a lot of interesting
preliminary data
suggesting that a combination of dietary
nitrate and citrulline
should be a pretty nice pretty cost
effective strategy for people who want
to build strength and muscle i think
aiming for a high nitrate diet with
citrulline supplementation about an
hour before workouts should be a good
way to promote training adaptations and
hypertrophy
over time uh unfortunately the the few
studies that i've actually tried to look
at hypertrophy within that context
the training programs just weren't well
suited for inducing hypertrophy
and in one case the nitrate dosage
that was provided just looking at
nitrate alone
wasn't sufficient and actually the one
looking at citrulline alone
uh the citrulline dose also was
insufficient it was very very low
and so it's one of those things that
it's almost more frustrating when
somebody kind of
starts to look at it but doesn't you
know doesn't kind of put all of that
together into a singular
cohesive approach where you've got a
sufficient hypertrophy stimulus and a
sufficient dosage
of both of those ingredients so i'd like
to see that one other thing i'd like to
see
is uh i'd like to see more experimental
work
uh really trying to precisely identify
optimal protein intakes in caloric
surpluses versus
caloric deficits and i'd like to see
those
uh those recommendations um
maybe more generalizably
scaled if generalizably that's a clunky
word not sure if it exists
but you know one of the things that kind
of drives me nuts is that a lot of the
protein recommendations
are grams per kilogram of total body
mass
and when you get to more extreme ranges
of the body composition spectrum i
struggle to believe that that's the best
way to scale it
uh and so i'd like to see uh
more studies looking at optimal protein
dosages both in caloric surpluses and
caloric deficits
with a very broad range of body
composition with regards to the
participants
so that we can really hone in on the
best way to scale that recommendation
across the spectrum of of body
composition
i feel like that wouldn't be a problem
if open data was a thing
oh no it'd be solved uh literally in
about 25 minutes
yeah that actually jogged my memory uh
another
area where i'd love to see research
where
shockingly there isn't any uh is
one of the things people talk about a
lot is how should you train in a deficit
like
ultimately something's got to give uh
you know as you're losing weight
probably going to lose some lean mass as
well performance is probably going to go
down
so is it better to try to maintain
training volume and sacrifice intensity
or try to maintain
intensity and sacrifice volume there's a
lot of people out there with some really
really strong takes on the topic
and there is precisely zero
data on the topic uh that is an area
that wide open research question
no research whatsoever and i'd i'd love
to see a study on that
definitely you could go on and on
because i mean at the end of each of our
mass articles we basically
say hey please do this study and so
every topic that i've written about i've
got like
i've got a recommendation i could lean
on but those are the ones that came to
top of mind for me
um okay i've got a question here from
fictional funkness
um and it relates to body fat percentage
so
how does an excessively low body fat
percentage
affect your ability to improve strength
and increase hypertrophy over time
part two of the question is given the
poor reliability of most body fat
measurement devices what's the best way
to ensure that an individual is in the
appropriate range for a given training
goal
so first of all when you've got a really
really low body fat
so you know talking about females
who have a body fat percentage you know
under
maybe 12 or 13 talking about males who
have a body fat percentage below
you know maybe seven or eight percent uh
when we start getting close to you know
essential body fat stores um
you know so when we're getting really
lean like physique
competition ready
gains are hard to come by on the
strength side they're hard to come by
because it's hard to really muster up uh
the energy
uh and the physiological uh
it's just hard to make good training
sessions happen i don't really know how
else to describe it uh
recovery is impacted um you know when
you're that lean
your leverages feel weird for the
exercises that you're training
uh glycogen starts to become an issue
where you're trying to drive through
those difficult reps and there's just
not a lot of
atp getting generated in a timely
fashion
it's just really hard to to to make
really notable strength gains assuming
that you uh were already strong and in a
well-trained state
uh before you lost the weight now if
you're totally untrained
and you you know diet down and you're
not exercising
and you get very very very lean and then
you start lifting of course
uh you know you're going to i would
assume uh
have some pretty notable strength gains
just from the uh
the the abrupt neuromuscular adaptations
that come with
dramatically improving your training
status in a short period of time but if
you're someone who's already strong
already has a lot of those neurological
and neuromuscular training adaptations
in place
it's really hard to make dramatic
strength gains when you're at a very
very low body fat percentage
it's hard to generate high quality
workouts
to muster up the energy for it and it's
hard to recover from session to session
on the hypertrophy side it's again very
very difficult to
to induce notable hypertrophy when
you're that lean
frankly because your your biological
resources are diverted elsewhere
it's really remarkable to see how your
body slows down and allocates energy
when you get down to those low body fat
percentages things you wouldn't expect
so like uh for example i cut my hair
less frequently
when i'm prepping for bodybuilding shows
my hair grows slower
uh i i don't have to trim my my
fingernails as frequently
like everything starts to slow down in
your body
and so you can see that reallocation of
biological resources
and so the idea that you're going to be
at five or six percent body fat and just
humming along and you know creating all
sorts of additional muscle tissue adding
all sorts of body protein
it's just not a realistic expectation
and when we were looking at the data
when we were
doing the p ratio analysis uh it it did
look like there was a bit of a cut off
where people
people under about eight percent body
fat uh
and in that case it would have all been
i believe males
down in the sub you know in the single
digits i don't think there were any
females in that data set
with body fat percentages down that low
but
looking at the data in total i don't
think there were any individuals making
really substantial gains in lean mass
under about eight percent body fat uh
which tracks pretty well with practical
experience
um so yeah it's very very difficult the
the only way you're going to really make
notable strength gains if you're
maintaining a super lean body
composition especially if you had to
diet to get down there
and it's not just your natural body
weight
the strength gains is just gonna it's
gonna depend on you being pretty
untrained beforehand
and then just getting some of those
beginner training adaptations
same thing goes for muscularity if it's
gonna happen it's gonna be because you
had
a pretty low uh degree of muscularity
and
pretty minimal muscle mass at the start
and we're just making some of those
beginner gains but
uh for the typical trainee who's been at
it for a while
very hard to come by now the other part
of the question
was given the the poor reliability of of
body comp
measurement how can you ensure that
you're in the appropriate range for your
training goal
and i really don't i don't view it as a
measurement issue
certainly the reliability and the
validity of body comp instrumentation
is a notable concern in some cases but
with this
the reason i don't think it's a
measurement issue is because everybody's
lower threshold
is a little bit different so some people
don't really start to feel
a lot of the crappy aspects of being
lean until they're
you know five percent body fat other
people start to feel it when they're up
around six or seven some people maybe at
eight or nine
you know everybody's got a slightly
different number below which they start
to say okay i'm really
feeling the fact that i'm lean right now
and my energy availability is low
so i even if we had uh really good body
comp measurements i don't think that
number is going to generalize perfectly
from person to person
so rather than relying on a body body
fat percentage measurement
i think it's much more important to go
by feel and when you're there
when you're in that position where
you're in a truly physiologically
altered state because of leanness
you're going to know you're going to
feel it when you're there
it's going to impact your recovery it's
going to impact your ability to muster
up that energy for a training session
you might notice other things that come
with it
you know increased hunger you might be a
little bit more cold throughout the day
just a bunch of other little things that
can give you an indication that your
body's like okay we're starting to get
some of those
neuroendocrine effects of being lean so
i think that's a much more
appropriate indicator rather than
relying on a body fat measurement
of any kind all right
astrup asks what are some fitness topics
where your opinion
is firmly against the common wisdom and
why
so uh yeah i mean ultimately i
am going to reject the premise of this
question uh
insofar as the idea that there is common
wisdom
in fitness uh i think that what people
perceive to be quote unquote common
wisdom
is incredibly niche specific
and people uh underestimate the degree
to which
what is perceived to be common wisdom
uh shared knowledge etc within their
specific niche really just
does not generalize to uh
you know everyone within the fitness
community um so for example
uh the the first thing that came to mind
for me was stretching
i'm i'm a big stretching head i think
it's good
stuff uh static stretching dynamic
stretching
pnf all of it my favorite though is
static stretching which might be
the most maligned of all um
and the the reason that my opinion is
firmly against
the common wisdom within my niche
is that i think people have
one just come to a completely erroneous
understanding
of the chronic effects of stretching and
two i think they're
over-reliant on acute studies that
may not generalize quite as well as they
think they do so
as far as the acute stuff goes there's
evidence showing if you do
fairly intense stretching for fairly
long duration
immediately before you assess maximum
velocity maximum
power output maximum force output that
can
decrease maximal velocity maximal power
output maximal force
output and so people say like ah well
you definitely don't want to do this
before training but
you know you have to keep experimental
models in mind
it's really intense stretching or for
really long durations and you're doing
it immediately before
your performance test other research has
shown if you do that stretching
and then you do any sort of like active
warm-up or just general warm-up
that lasts for more than like 10 minutes
or so performance goes back to normal so
i
i don't think that's that much of a
concern um
and then as far as the
erroneous understanding of the chronic
effects of of static stretching go
i've seen this claim repeated so many
times that if if i had a nickel for
every time i saw it
i'd probably have like maybe two or
three bucks which is kind of a lot when
you think about it
um that if you stretch
it's it's only uh causing a
short-term neural effect
so it's acutely increasing stretch
tolerance
you can get a few extra degrees of range
of motion from that and then
you know 20 minutes later your your
flexibility is back to where it was
before
and chronically stretching isn't
actually going to
increase flexibility or mobility i have
no [ __ ] idea where that idea started
from
uh it is quite frankly insane it
contradicts uh an enormous amount of
of literature and also just doesn't even
pass the reality test
like if you look at any of the athletes
in any of the sports that have
uh truly exceptional flexibility so
you know gymnasts dancers uh
martial arts athletes and certain
martial arts they got that way because
they do
a ton of stretching and have from a very
young age like it
uh it absolutely causes
longitudinal chronic increases in
flexibility and i
do not know how people got the idea that
it didn't uh but that's like a pretty
common
claim i'll see which again quite frankly
completely unhinged um
but yeah so in that regard i'm
i think firmly outside the mainstream of
like the
strength training power lifting snc
maybe bodybuilding community uh but then
i thought about it more and i was like
well it's hard to say that's outside the
common wisdom of the fitness community
because like
i don't know [ __ ] yoga exists
and they do they do a ton of stretching
for the express purpose of increasing
flexibility and range of motion and
you know other things as well but like
you know uh
it's it's hard to say that it's common
wisdom that
stretching doesn't chronically increase
flexibility and range of motion
and is a bad thing to do because there's
large swaths of the fitness community
where that's just taken as a truism
and you know half of what they do is
stretching so
you know it and i i think that that
i think that that generalizes a ton to
almost everything
like uh you know it common wisdom within
the strength training bodybuilding
community about protein
intake you're going to get very
different common
common wisdom regarding protein intake
and protein recommendations
if you spend much time in like a vegan
endurance athlete
part of the fitness community which like
does exist and is pretty big
uh so yeah i mean i i can't think of a
single piece of common wisdom that is
just
generally shared across the entirety of
the fitness community so
i kind of reject the premise uh one of
the other things as well is even within
communities what is perceived to be
common wisdom
shifts over time and i i can't think of
a better example of that than uh
then ideas about ideal training
frequency
for strength gain and muscle growth so i
i got into lifting
not that long ago uh 2000
yeah i get i guess it was kind of a long
time ago
it was like 2005 2006 uh and back then
the standard advice was to train with a
low frequency
uh so you know one time per
per muscle group or per lift per week or
maybe two if you have a lagging lift
lagging body part and
and you're not afraid to be a little bit
aggressive with it uh
and these days i mean we get questions
to our
our q a uh little form
where people are like hey can you still
build muscle
if you only train a muscle group once
per week um
so that the common wisdom regarding
ideal frequency has completely
shifted from only train once per week
unless you want to over train and die
to is it even possible to make
to to cause significant hypertrophy if
you're only training a muscle group once
per week
uh so you know if there's any sort of
like longitudinal component
to the idea of common wisdom within
fitness
i definitely don't think that there's
anything that's just generally shared
across the entire
uh fitness community so yeah
i don't know it's hard to say what uh
which of my ideas are firmly outside the
mainstream because i wouldn't even feel
confident taking a swing at what the
mainstream is
you know another great example of that
change within
a particular group in terms of the
consensus
is if you look at the history of
strength and conditioning
for the longest time if you were a team
sport athlete
uh in like any sport they did not want
you lifting weights
oh yeah i mean they're like you know if
you've got my
my linebackers lifting weights they're
going to get slow and they're going to
lose flexibility they're not going to be
able to play the game
uh and it was surprisingly not that long
ago that that was the prevailing
perspective
uh and then all of a sudden you know
we've got our punters doing reps with
225 at the combine
you know so it's been a huge change
where uh
having someone who's just a total
beast in the weight room is a selling
point now for a recruit or for a draft
pick
in in in certain sports and uh you know
not that long ago not that many decades
ago if people found out that you were
lifting regularly they're like ah he's
probably going to slow down a lot he's
probably not going to be able to compete
so yeah that stuff changes all the time
okay i've got a question here from peter
so peter does his workouts in the
morning
and he acknowledges in the question he
says i understand that this limits my
absolute performance the weight on the
bar the repetitions completed
the question is how much does that
actually matter for a non-competitive
trainee who's focused on something like
health
or hypertrophy or something like that uh
you know so
if i'm doing three sets of ten on the
bench press with
you know two reps in reserve doesn't
matter if the weight is
10 or 15 pounds lower uh you know
because i'm training in the morning
fasted
uh so i want to answer this in a couple
ways
uh first of all
i want to talk about the direct question
that was asked
but then i want to chat i want to
contextualize the implication
that fasted training necessarily
uh in all cases is going to hinder
performance
so the first part uh performance matters
some in an absolute sense uh
but the goal is is really critical to
consider here so
if you're just training for general
health goals the
absolute performance of what you're
doing in the gym we have a ton of wiggle
room there
we don't have to worry about it too much
if you're training because you want to
make sure that you maintain
activities of daily living as you age we
don't need every training session to be
you know just an absolutely perfect
effort
we don't need to make sure that we've
optimized every aspect of your program
getting in there doing some hard stuff
and then recovering before the next time
is probably going to be enough if health
is the primary objective as long as
you're performing pretty well
to the best of your ability there's a
lot of wiggle room there
body composition goals we got to do a
little bit better than that
you know it's it's not the top of that
spectrum or
the furthest end of that spectrum which
is
if you've got a performance specific
goal a performance-oriented goal
you got to make sure you're performing
well in your training sessions in my
opinion you got you got to be trying
to optimize that performance in the gym
getting better over time but
body composition goals are kind of in
the middle there where
the goal is not necessarily
to optimize every aspect of your
performance we still want to perform
well in those sessions because
hypertrophy you know we'll talk about
all these different mechanisms
that drive hypertrophy and you know
providing that mechanical tension to the
muscle fiber is important
and i struggle to uh
i struggle to believe that the weight on
the bar is completely inconsequential
or or the number of repetitions we
complete is is inconsequential i think
uh if we're trying to maximize
hypertrophy we want to be performing
well so that we can
provide plenty of mechanical tension in
a time efficient manner
now that doesn't you you could argue the
degree to which it matters but
i think if you look at it on really big
extremes
just absolutely terrible performance
versus
absolutely optimized performance there's
probably going to be a difference there
for the trainee who's trying to maximize
hypertrophy
so yeah i mean we want to perform well
but the degree to which we sweat over
the details is going to vary based on
your goal
and it really doesn't make sense to to
sweat too much over that stuff
if you're really health focused if
you're very performance focused you
probably ought to be sweating over the
details
and if your main goals are body
composition you're probably somewhere in
the middle there
but it never hurts to perform well in
the gym especially when the reason we're
in the gym
is to apply mechanical tension to the
muscle fibers
um now one thing i did want to
uh mention here is that the performance
detriment associated with fasted
training
is still relatively uncertain it's not
like rejected
but there is some nuance to consider
there so there was a study back in the
day
i forget the author but they looked at
you know giving people either a carb
heavy breakfast or
just a water placebo and looking at
their resistance training performance
and
relatively unsurprisingly it was better
to have a breakfast than no breakfast
but that same group did a follow-up
study where they had the the carb heavy
breakfast they also had the water
condition
but they also had a placebo breakfast
that basically just
filled you up and you felt like you ate
something and you did
but there there wasn't really a lot of
caloric content to speak
of and it certainly wasn't rich in
carbohydrates so
wasn't it just like basically glute yeah
it was this
like i think it was orange flavored
psyllium husk yeah it was this orange
favor
flavored like just kind of jelly
kind of substance that really didn't
have considerable caloric content
and so uh what was really interesting
was that the carb heavy breakfast again
outperformed water but the
minimal calorie glute
just orange stuff uh actually
led to pretty similar performance as the
carb heavy breakfast
and so the conclusion there was you know
you definitely don't want to be training
hungry
that's probably not a good thing for
your performance but when it comes to
the actual
energy content of the meal it raised
some
interesting questions that in my opinion
we still haven't really figured out
exactly how much
uh the energy content of the breakfast
matters when training early in the
morning
it seems like something is better than
nothing but there's a
considerable amount of debate in terms
of
do you just need to stave off hunger
during your workout or you do you
actually need to provide
critical macronutrients and if so which
ones
um now i i think you could also
argue that uh you you i mean
like i said you don't want to be
training hungry you probably don't want
to be training super carb depleted
especially if you're doing relatively
glycolytic resistance training work
um breakfast uh a lot of these studies
are focusing on do you need it if so
how should it be designed your breakfast
in terms of the the macronutrients
maybe it's not as critical if the
nighttime meal
is sufficient so if you have a really
big meal at night before uh you know
before you go to sleep maybe the
composition of
of the nighttime feeding strategy the
day before
kind of alleviates the need to have a
really elaborate breakfast before you
train
uh and you could argue that's probably
even more so the case if you have some
kind of intra-workout feeding strategy
so
the takeaway is not that you know we
have strong evidence that you definitely
should be training in a fasted state and
it doesn't have any
negative ramifications but it's still
kind of an open question and the more
evidence we get the more frustrating it
gets because
it's hard to put together a really
cohesive picture i would say
that the most parsimonious approach and
the most conservative approach
approach for someone who wants to really
make sure that they're performing well
in the gym
is to at least have a light breakfast if
you're training you know first thing in
the morning if you can stomach it
something that at the bare minimum has
maybe 20 grams of carbs maybe you throw
some protein in there as well
i probably wouldn't go super high on the
fat just because it takes a long time to
digest
so i think some small snack before
training is probably a good idea if
if it agrees with your stomach but if it
makes you nauseous to train with food in
your stomach
and you know for some reason liquid a
liquid meal isn't going to be an
option you could be doing more harm than
good
if you're inducing an upset stomach
before you go into trains so
it's a nuanced question i wanted to make
sure that i at least addressed some of
those nuances
uh before moving on to the next one
so connor smith asked this is one of the
few ones that i got from
uh the thread that you put up so
conor smith said greg in previous
episodes
has talked about his pet peeve of people
saying correlation doesn't imply
causation
in situations where it's not really
relevant and nobody's actually implying
causation
so conor asks on a statistical level
what does imply causation
and he also asked what kind of
statistical analysis would i do
to basically provide support for a
causative statement
or a statement that directly suggests
causation
uh so i wanted to briefly answer this
because it's something that comes up
so frequently but the idea of
making inferences about causation you
know it's one thing to say that two
things are correlated that that's a low
bar to clear
if if the two things seem to change in
unison
either you know one goes up the other
goes up one goes up the
other goes down it's very
very easy to make statements about
correlation there's not a really high
bar to clear there
but when we make statements about
causation we say that one thing is
causing another we have to do a lot more
work to really defend that type of
statement we it requires a much
a much different level of evidence but
causation
is not about the statistical analysis
it's more about the study
design when we're talking about research
so
one of the reasons that people say oh
correlation doesn't cause or
doesn't imply uh causation is because a
lot of times we're using correlation in
observational
research so we're looking at a big
population of people and we're saying
hey
the people who ate more fast food had
higher rates of you know
coronary heart disease or whatever
and so you can look at that correlation
and say hey that seems kind of bad
but you're still just making
observations you're not doing a tightly
controlled experiment where you're
controlling for compounding variables
you're randomizing groups to different
interventions
it's just simply a very uh high level
observation that doesn't require uh or
doesn't involve a great degree of
control
in in the uh in the study now when you
contrast that with something
like a randomized controlled trial where
we basically identify the key variables
that need to be
literally controlled and we randomize
people to receive one treatment or the
other and they don't know which
treatment they've received
and we look at how the treatment uh
impacts a very specific outcome over
time
and we test that with you know some some
type of inferential statistics
the reason we can make uh causative
statements there if the
study was designed well is because of
the design it's not because of the
the analysis done so you if you wanted
to you could go find some observational
data
you could arbitrarily group it however
you want you could run
a t-test which is you often used in
randomized controlled trials as the
analysis
but you can't say oh this isn't a
correlation it's a t-test now we've got
causation here
right i mean it's really about the study
design
and not the statistical analysis
employed
a t-test is still correlation yes it is
but you know people look at a randomized
controlled trial that uses a t-test
and they they think oh that's that's
causative stuff no i i know and i know
you know a t-test is correlation yeah
yeah i mean uh
i feel like a lot of people don't know
that they they see a t-test and they're
like oh this is
a fundamentally different thing than
pearson regression but
no the the math that powers them is the
same yes uh and yeah so
uh whether you're talking about
correlation regression t-test
anova they all fall within the general
linear model
framework and the the nuts and bolts uh
you know the math behind it is all the
same but but it just uh
yeah it's all about how your predictors
are coded basically
uh is what determines those differences
there uh
now there is some stuff i i should
acknowledge this uh
if you're getting into other fields you
really don't see this much
in the exercise and the sport nutrition
literature but
you may come across something called
structural equation modeling
uh or or similar procedures that have
kind of stemmed out from it
and it causes a lot of confusion if if
you google
structural equation modeling causation
you're going to find like the first
million results that i'll say like
clearing up the confusion about
sem and causation so so it sounds like
that confusion has been
thoroughly cleared up well if so then
they wouldn't need a thousand posts to
go back and through it
but so one of the things that's tricky
there is sometimes people use
structural equation modeling with
observational data
um and what you do is you kind of you
kind of make some assumptions
about this causative pathway and the
things that kind of
mediate or interfere with this causative
pathway
you you create uh
a kind of diagram so to speak
that needs to make some assumptions
about causal relationships
and and that kind of forms the framework
for the analysis and
i'll be very clear i've never done sem
but that's kind of like the general
overview is that it involves
kind of plotting out a causal pathway
incorporating other elements into the
analysis and so
what what's tricky is that some people
think
when they look at that oh cool so now we
can infer causation but
again if the data were not generated
uh with a with a design that allows you
to make claims about causation
there's no amount of sophisticated
modeling that can really get you over
that bar
causation is a study design issue not an
analytical approach issue
you can do some approaches that are
maybe
maybe give you a little bit more freedom
to kind of
drift toward those types of statements
but if you really want to make a strong
inferences
a strong inference about causation it
comes down to having a really tight
study design
where you really do have a high degree
of experimental control
another thing that if you're really
interested in causation you want to do
some additional reading
there's something called the bradford
hill criteria that are
very commonly applied uh it's a group of
nine principles that can be useful in
establishing
uh epidemiologic evidence of a causal
relationship
but but again it's it's kind of just
trying to establish what are we looking
for
when we try to make inferences related
to causation
i'm sure people argue back and forth
about the exact criteria that ought to
be implemented but
a lot of times you'll see people who
will say you know what
we don't really have a good randomized
controlled trial on this
but if we use you know this list of
criteria
it kind of seems like there might be a
causative relationship between
x and y uh so if you're really
interested in
what goes into establishing causation
and different perspectives
on it you can look up the bradford hill
criteria and probably spend the next
10 years reading about it yeah i uh
when you were said you were going to
answer that question i went ahead and
got the bradford hill criteria pulled up
and i was
hoping to have something to contribute
but i suppose i do not
actually i do have one thing to add and
that is just
the the concept of causation
i think uh is is a concept that people
get muddled
uh because causation means different
things in different contexts
and when most people think
of causation they think of something
where like
a necessarily entails b or a necessarily
leads to b
uh and that that is the type of
causation
that one can establish in say
in vitro research so if uh
if you're trying to develop say a
protein that will fit in a receptor
uh just right you could say like
okay if we make a protein with this
particular amino acid sequence
it will bind to this receptor with
this degree of affinity if it comes in
contact with it
and that's something where it's a very
controlled environment
um in like on
on a molecular atomic level
you can see a necessarily entails b if
the protein is shaped like this
it will bind to this receptor with this
degree of affinity
that is not what we're talking about
typically
when we're making causal type statements
uh when we're dealing with in vivo
research when we're dealing with entire
organisms
so you know let's say someone does a
really really good randomized control
trial
on the effects of creatine on muscle
growth or something like that
you have random sampling which is ideal
but we never do
uh you have random group allocation uh
and everything's blinded subjects don't
know if they're in the the creatine or
the placebo arm
researchers don't know who's in what arm
everything is
done the way you would want it to be
done to establish the
causal relationship between creatine
supplementation and muscle growth
um in a situation like that
you're still going to have variability
in muscle growth there will be some
subjects who didn't take creatine who
grow more than some of the subjects who
did take creatine
there's going to be a lot of variability
within both groups
and so someone who's dealing with that
kind of
molecular understanding of causation
would look at that and say like
this isn't a necessarily entails b
this isn't this sort of like one-to-one
causal relationship that i think of when
i think causation
but when we're dealing with in vivo
research we're
almost necessarily dealing with
partial causation so there's going to be
a lot of factors
that influence responses
to whatever stimulus you're you're
placing on people
uh and you're trying to establish if the
intervention itself
is one of those causes so you're not
going to deal with like
perfect one-to-one correlations you're
not going to be seeing
a necessarily entails b but if you
get a pretty strong significant finding
in a well-designed well-controlled
well-conducted rct
you're you're establishing partial
causation there so
you're basically establishing that
whatever you're investigating
is one of the factors that contributes
to the outcome
that you're interested in not
necessarily that it's a one-to-one
relationship that's
that's not the type of causal
relationship that
we look for in in in vivo research
all right good stuff uh so i guess we're
gonna close
out uh with the best questions saved it
for last
yeah so uh agreeable ad zero one one one
asks
is cereal really just a soup justify
your answer please
do you want to lead off um
[Music]
i would say yes uh i would say cereal is
a soup because a soup doesn't have to be
hot there are plenty of cold soups
and when you think of a soup you're
thinking of
you know some solid food stuff well not
always but in many cases
uh some kind of solid food stuff that
is submerged in
a a liquid broth and that broth
often has uh multiple components to it
such as a milk product
so uh i would say as long as the cereal
is being consumed in the traditional
format
with some type of milk product i would
say yes
now if the cereal is being consumed
outside of that context
then the answer would be no and you know
i've used cereals
in many different ways in my uh cooking
in the past so
i think it's contextually uh dependent
upon
putting the cereal in a bowl-like
container and pouring in an adequate
amount of a milk product
yeah no i i agree wholeheartedly i think
cereal is
absolutely a soup again if it's if it's
served with milk
um so i i would
count myself a soup maximalist and i
think
you you have to be if you
just do enough research on what is
commonly considered a soup
and when you see the the broad array of
things that
can be considered soups and are
considered soups
i think that that variability
necessarily entails that
most most
liquid based things with other things
mixed in
are there for soups so uh
when when people think about soups so
one of the common things that will come
up is like ooh
ooh yeah cereal is a soup because soups
don't have to be hot
what about gazpacho uh but that's still
like kind of savory so some
so a cereal soup skeptic could push back
against
against it and say like well yeah i mean
gazpacho
is is a cold soup but i mean that's
that's very different from
cereal like the whole flavor profile is
different
but if you go to the wikipedia article
about soup which
you should that's that's where all of
the good research is done
there are dessert soups so this isn't
necessarily something
that would uh be top of mind
say for americans but there are dessert
soups from
vietnam the philippines japan
china and trinidad and tobago
that are listed on the wikipedia page
and the first one which i'm going to
butcher the pronunciation of but i think
it would be pronounced
che is a vietnamese cold dessert soup
containing sugar and coconut milk uh
with many different varieties of other
ingredients including
taro cassava adzuki bean mung bean
jackfruit and durian and and
specifically focusing on
things like uh
like adzuki beans like beans you know
you're you're dealing with
starchy staple crops
which you know most uh most cereals
themselves are going to be
corn based or wheat based or barley
based
uh and like barley soup itself is a
thing so
you know you can't really tell me that
processing that grain
product makes it less of a soup so
the sheer existence of dessert soups i
think makes it a pretty
open and shut case that um
that cereal is a soup as well i didn't
realize this
until i went to the wikipedia page but
apparently fruit soup
is a thing as well um i don't know how i
feel about that
but i mean who am i to tell people that
they're wrong
and yeah i mean if fruit soups can be a
thing then
yeah sure cereal is absolutely a soup
i think once you account for fruit soups
and
dessert soups you necessarily have to be
a soup maximalist
and there are there are many soups in
this
wild and wonderful world you know i i
don't know if my eyes deceive me right
now but i
i did some wikipedia searching uh
followed from
link to link wound up somewhere but i'm
looking at a banana soup
and first of all it looks delicious uh
everything about it looks great
it looks like so it's got banana it's
got milk
but it looks like there are maybe some
vanilla wafers
or some type of sweet processed grain
product sitting up on top of it
and uh first of all it just sounds
incredible
and looks incredible but if those are
vanilla wafers then this basically is
cereal
because some people do cut up banana and
put it in their cereal
yeah yeah for sure i mean we we
literally have
photographic evidence to support our our
idea here
so yeah uh to answer the question uh
trex and i for once on a food topic are
in agreement
uh cereal is absolutely a soup tell it
to the haters
uh yeah any anyone who
who doesn't accept that
uh they're they're not welcome
in our in our audience and pop-tarts are
a form of ravioli
correct yeah they're a sweet ravioli
that shouldn't be controversial
uh lasagna spaghetti flavored cake as
i'm sure we're all aware
um there there are many things yep
all right well i think that does it for
this episode as always thank you for
listening and we will be back
in two weeks thank you for listening to
the stronger by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs
for all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do
so we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
[Music]
podcast
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you